for the past week this has been sarah
muhammad's home she left the mazin in
sudan's blue nile state when fighting
broke out between the hausa and berta
tribes she and her children walked for
hours to reach neighborings in our state
we heard that there was fighting in
parts of blue nile between our tribe and
other tribes and we immediately fled it
took us more than six hours of walking
to get here and now we have nothing
except what we were given by the host
communities
sarah is one of thousands displaced by
the unrest and one of the few to have
settled with the host community other
families have found shelter in abandoned
schools in sinar
but thousands of families are displaced
in blue now state itself
some haven't found anywhere to stay and
are stuck outside in the middle of the
rainy season
delivering aid to those in need is no
easy task some areas are hard to access
because of the violence and while aid
organizations wait for security
conditions to improve people are
becoming more and more desperate
many say they've lost everything
i escaped with nothing except the
clothes i'm wearing no one has come to
see what our needs are there are people
with chronic diseases and children
needing help we need someone to come and
provide us with assistance
the conflict started when the hauser
tried to establish a tribal
administration and laid claim to land
the berta and other tribes rejected the
move and fighting broke out more than
100 people were killed the government
has imposed the curfew and banned large
gatherings in two cities
but as long as tribal hostilities
persist getting help to those who need
it will remain a challenge hiba morgan
al jazeera demozene in blue now state